[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité les décorations de
Noël seront-elles cette année en berne
symbole des fêtes de fin d'année elles
doivent-elles aussi faire preuve de
sobriété reportage dans les locaux d'une
entreprise fabricante dès le début de ce
journal avec Alain TV Sarthe dans ce
journal également une immersion chez les
experts à la française comme dans la
série américaine les gendarmes de la
cellule d'identification criminelle nous
dévoilerons quelques-uns de leur secret
la rédaction de télé Grenoble a pu se
rendre dans leur locaux
manger dans l’air à 50 mètres de hauteur
avec une vue imprenable sur le lac Léman
c'est l'expérience gastronomique un peu
folle que viennent de vivre des clients
une idée venue de Belgique qui en plus
d'être aérienne est aussi locale dans
l'assiette nous dira la rédaction de 8
monts blancs et puis enfin de journal
nous prendrons la direction de la somme
pour découvrir la seconde vie d'une
piscine devenue un lieu d'exposition des
graves aquatiques dans les bassins et
les vestiaires un sujet de Wéo TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord
vont-elles se faire plus discrète dans
nos rues cet hiver les décorations de
Noël sont l'un des emblèmes de la féerie
des fêtes de fin d'année petite ou
grande elle n'en reste pas moins soumise
aux problématiques de l'actualité et de
la crise énergétique alors pour tenter
de rassurer les collectivités les
entreprises du secteur promettent des
décorations de moins en moins
énergivores objectif pour elle sauver
leur carnet de commandes et les emplois
exemple dans un atelier de décoration
spécialisée avec ce reportage d'Enzo
Maubert pour LM TV Sarthe
les décors scintillent déjà dans cet
atelier c'est le grand rush on câble on
accroche et on illumine des milliers de
décorations de Noël un décor majestueux
comme celui-là les collectivités en
raffolent mais avec la crise énergétique
beaucoup ont tardé à passer commande
résultat l'entreprise a perdu 40 % de
son chiffre d'affaires au mois de
septembre il y a quelques jours la
production a finalement retrouvé sac à
danse habituel un gros travail de
pédagogie et de communication de la part
de nos équipes sur le terrain pour
expliquer en fait que nos décors ne
consomment pas beaucoup d'énergie
principale argument la LED aujourd'hui
toutes les décorations sont équipées une
petite révolution qui permet de réduire
de 90% la consommation d'électricité si
on prend l'exemple de la rue des Minimes
au Mans lorsqu'elle est illuminée
pendant 45 jours la rue des Minimes
consomme rien que pour ses illuminations
260 kWh et 260 kWh ça représente la
consommation annuelle d'une seule box
internet mais l'entreprise ne s'arrête
pas là elle a aussi développé ce boîtier
une sorte d'interrupteur branché aux
illuminations qui permet de les piloter
à distance ces synchronisé avec une
application que les agents techniques
dans les collectivités peut avoir sur
leur smartphone ça permet vraiment de
d'optimiser la durée d'allumage des
décors et de d'allumer les décors que
quand on a du monde en ville de quoi
rassurer les municipalités Le Mans et
l'aval ont d'ores et déjà annoncé
qu’elle ne réduirait pas le nombre
d'illuminations par rapport aux années
précédentes une bonne nouvelle pour
l'entreprise sarthoise qui produit et
livre tous les ans plus de 25000 décors
lumineux à travers le monde
voilà de la magie de Noël à la réalité
du quotidien c'est le porte-monnaie des
Français qui est mis à mal depuis
plusieurs mois entre l'inflation la
flambée des prix de l'énergie et les
pénuries dans certains secteurs alors si
l'ensemble du pays est évidemment touché
les territoires d'outre-mer aussi le son
en Martinique les commerçants et les
artisans sont obligés d'augmenter les
prix pour s'acquitter leur charge
exemple dans un garage et une
boulangerie vous allez voir un sujet
devant le Mare pour via TV
dans cette carrosserie la hausse des
prix est un vrai coup dur ici
l'inflation rime avec augmentation des
charges et pénuries de pièces avec de
longs impacts sur l'entreprise et sa
clientèle un véhicule qui a un simple
choc
arrivera rapidement à la situation de
d'être en différence de valeur
c'est-à-dire que le montant de la
réparation va coûter plus cher que la
valeur du véhicule avec ses hausse de
prix la gestion de la trésorerie est de
plus en plus compliquée les délais de
réparation sont de plus en plus longs le
plus souvent on a 5-6000 7000 euros de
pièces pour pour une simple réparation
on n'est pas payé
très rapidement il y a quand même un
délai dans cette boulangerie même
constat le coût des matières premières
et les charges sont passées du simple au
double
achetez 23 € et puis on vous dit que
vous le payez à 33 euros c'est pas une
augmentation pour nous ça c'est exagéré
pour faire face le gérant a augmenté
légèrement ses prix mais la situation
reste tendue
qui doit s'asseoir avec nous pour qu'on
puisse l'habiller parler au sol du côté
des clients on gère comme on peut mais
c'est vrai que je me déplace en faisant
la liste de ce que je dois faire je
groupe ça et je sois une fois ou deux
fois par semaine pour les gérants comme
pour les clients les aides mises en
place par le gouvernement reste
insuffisante ils espèrent tous une
baisse rapide des prix
une baisse des prix espérée aussi en
métropole et surtout dans les quartiers
les plus fragiles où la situation
économique peut impacter jusqu'aux
besoins essentiel de chacun en
Île-de-France le département du
Val-d'Oise offre désormais le petit
déjeuner dans des établissements issus
du réseau d'éducation prioritaire au
menu boisson chaude céréales pinces ou
encore fruits pour bien débuter la
journée explication au micro d'Elisa
zanettage journaliste pour via 84
on se rend compte que dans beaucoup de
collèges les enfants
arrivent sans avoir pris des petits
déjeuners ça occasionne de la fatigue au
cours de la matinée et puis surtout
beaucoup moins de concentration par
exemple moi chez moi je peux pas tout
prendre tout ce qui est là je peux
prendre des céréales je prends pas tout
des poireaux de la salade du persil des
choux du fenouil ou encore des
betteraves les légumes prennent le
pouvoir à Limoges la ville vient de
lancer son opération de culture légumes
dans les espaces jusque-là réservés aux
fleurs objectif à terme distribué à la
population les aliments cultivés en
milieu urbain les précisions micro de
Benjamin Delmas de la rédaction de cet
aliment sur place
volonté aujourd'hui dans la période de
sobriété qu'on traverse c'est de faire
de l'utile en plus de faire du beau donc
au lieu de cultiver des fleurs qui sont
visées purement décoratifs là on cultive
des légumes dans l'objectif de
développer la ville nourricière
aujourd'hui on les plante
la volonté dans l'idéal ce serait de les
récolter de les mettre à disposition du
public sauf qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
sûr de la qualité du sol on ne peut pas
garantir non plus qu'il soit propre à la
consommation du fait de leur situation
dans l'espace public nous faut qu'on
s'assure de ces éléments là avant de
mettre à disposition les légumes à la
consommation la faune et la flore encore
dans ce journal car nuisible pour la
biodiversité évolue d'été le frelons
étant cette période automnale en pleine
reproduction moment idéal pour
s'attaquer au nid et se débarrasser de
l'espèce qui aime trouver refuge dans
les recoins des bâtiments les
interventions des spécialistes sont
encore nombreuses actuellement lisent à
Hervé a suivi l'une d'entre elles
pourvient Occitanie regarder
voilà c'est ici que les frelons se sont
installés juste dans l'avancée de toi là
il y a trois semaines Thierry a
découvert un nid de frelons asiatique
sous les tuiles de sa maison endroit où
loger jusque là des abeilles on vient
pas tranquillement là ils sont vraiment
à si on regarde ils sont à 3 mètres de
la table on peut manger dehors et on
peut plus manger dehors là c'est
dès qu'on ouvre dès qu'on ouvre les
volets ou les fenêtres ils essaient de
rentrer alors pour ne prendre aucun
risque a appelé un exterminateur de
frelons un spécialiste équipé et
disposant des bons produits pour
pour le protéger il faut quand même
traiter la zone pour se faire Guillaume
utilise un insecticide naturel qui agit
sur le système nerveux les frelons
meurent d'asphyxie au bout de 3 à 10
minutes c'est une espèce invasive
il détruit les abeilles il détruit toute
la biodiversité il va se nourrir
vraiment de tout ce qui trouve donc il
déstabilise complètement les écosystèmes
les chaînes alimentaires
il vaut mieux le détruire au maximum on
n'arrivera jamais à l'éradiquer
maintenant qu'il est dispersé dans la
nature c'est complètement impossible à
éradiquer il va falloir apprendre à
vivre à vivre avec en cette période de
reproduction Guillaume retire par jour 4
assignies de frelons asiatiques ou
européens
voilà elles font souvent rêvées et sont
toujours scénarisés notamment rendu
populaire par la série télé les experts
les cellules d'identification criminelle
de la gendarmerie veille chaque jour à
démasquer les apparences pour faire la
lumière sur les scènes de crime alors du
prélèvement des indices à l'analyse en
laboratoire les techniques employées
sont de plus en plus performantes et
permettent de résoudre des affaires
parfois des années après les faits
visite dans les locaux de la CIC cette
brigade de l'Isère avec Lucie Dailly de
télé Grenoble
à première vue ces bouteilles
rafraîchissent en cellules mais si elle
séjourne dans cette cuve c'est pour
révéler leur secret dans quelques
minutes des particules de colle
chauffées vont se déposer sur des
empreintes digitales et les rendre
visibles démasquer les apparences c'est
la mission de la cellule
d'identification criminelle de la
gendarmerie qui doit contribuer à
résoudre des enquêtes en observant
collectant et analysant tous les
éléments matériels des scènes de crimes
et délits la première chose qu'on fait
quand on arrive sur une scène de crime
d'abord cette fixer les lieux avec des
films faire des photographies faire des
plans des croquis etc etc ensuite on va
rechercher les différents indices qui
vont nous permettre de mettre en cause
un individu dans ce dossier les indices
sont mis sous scellés et envoyés dans
les locaux de la CIC ou les techniciens
procéderont à leur analyse on a un
stéréo microscope qui va nous permettre
de agrandir les éléments pileux pour
voir si effectivement on a des bulbes ou
pas
on a des générateurs de lumière avec
différentes longueurs d'onde qui nous
permettent de mettre en évidence des
traces qui sont invisibles à l’œil nu
cet appareil on appelle ça une vacumbox
ça nous permet de faire des recherches
de traces de foulage quand vous écrivez
sur un cahier on peut relire plusieurs
feuilles après ce que vous avez noté au
terme de la recherche les gendarmes de
la cellule d'identification criminelle
rédige leur conclusion en élaborant
différents scénarii et parfois des mois
voire des années après les faits grâce
au progrès des technologies et grâce
aussi à la fois des enquêteurs et des
gendarmes de la CIC dont l'obstination a
souvent permis de découvrir des traces
inespérées comme l'ADN de la petite
Maëlys dans la voiture de Nordahl
Lelandais en Isère chaque année on
recense 40 000 crimes et délits sur les
522 communes de la zone gendarmerie
et de la gendarmerie aux
sapeurs-pompiers dans ce journal
découvrons la formation des futurs
soldats du feu mineurs les jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers aussi appelé les GPS
sont formés généralement une ou deux
fois par semaine pendant plusieurs
années au programme éducation au gestes
de premiers secours technique de lutte
contre les incendies ou encore activités
sportives pour ses pompiers en
apprentissage un reportage passionnant
de Canal 32 dans l'eau pour regarder
en avant marche Go
discipline rigueur et conditions
physiques autant de qualité et de
compétences demandées par l'école des
jeunes sapeurs-pompiers on les forme
suivant un programme qui est progressif
suivant justement là j'ai adapté avec
pour objectif d'avoir un gain de temps
de formation et d'avoir dès le
recrutement en qualité de volontaire un
pompier formé quasiment à 100% pendant 4
ans à partir de 13 ans les jeunes sont
formés par des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires ou professionnels bénévoles
le plus compliqué pour pour former un
jeune on va dire que c'est surtout bien
culquer en fait une rigueur en fait une
rigueur que bah il y a pas l'extérieur
souvent on sait qu'il y a les études à
prendre en compte voilà on peut avoir le
brevet ou même les premières épreuves du
bac mais faut réussir à jongler entre
les deux actuellement dans l'Aube 161
jeunes sapeurs-pompiers suivent la
formation chaque samedi entre manœuvres
et court théorique le but garder les
élèves motivés c'est un vrai corps on
essaye de créer une cohésion on parle
souvent de la grande famille des
pompiers on a aussi une grande famille
chez les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers qui
fait partie aussi de la famille des
pompiers la motivation est essentielle
pour intégrer l'école des apprentis
soldats du feu j'aime être utile j'aime
venir en aide c'est un tout c'est le
manœuvre c'est
c'est l'équipe entre guillemets j'ai
voulu être ici parce que déjà le milieu
des pompiers des pompiers me plaît
beaucoup j'aime bien ce côté où on va on
est formé pour après aller aider les
gens à l'issue de la formation il se
voit remettre un brevet national qui
leur permet d'être embauché comme sa
peur pompier volontaire
voilà c'est une histoire de passion et
de courage donc pour ces adolescents
sapeurs-pompiers du courage justement il
faut en avoir un peu pour manger à 50
mètres de hauteur vous l'avez vu dans
les titres c'est l'expérience inédite
convaincue récemment des clients
au-dessus du lac Léman le principe est
simple partager le repas d'un grand chef
à bord d'une plateforme dans un cadre à
couper le souffle Lucas Rouck a pris
place autour de cette table étonnante
sensation garantie avec la chaîne 8
Mont-Blanc regarder merci à plus de 50
mètres de haut avec une vue à 360° sur
Thonon et le lac Léman le tout autour
d'un repas gastronomique ça n'arrive pas
tous les jours voici à bord de dinner in
the sky une expérience de tous les
superlatifs
on mange bien c'est une super expérience
après Monaco ou encore Bruxelles le
concept débarque cette semaine sur les
rives du Léman avec un seul et même
objectif celui de mettre en valeur le
tissu local on essaie de créer un lien
avec le patrimoine gastronomique local
donc par exemple ici ce sont tous des
chefs de la région qui viennent on va
pas se demander un chef de Paris par
exemple devenir travailler devenir
cuisiner ici à Thonon-les-Bains pareil
par rapport aux produits qui sont
utilisés ils vont travailler
principalement les chefs ici avec des
produits du terroir mettre les produits
du terroir en avant et donc l'idée c'est
de vraiment de faire découvrir que ce
soit la population locale ou à des
touristes éventuellement qui viennent de
l'étranger découvrir ces produits là
côté cuisine c'est tout un challenge ils
sont une poignée à cuisiner réessayer
servir les nombreux plats on est quatre
à servir 22 personnes dans un endroit
assez restreint les mouvements sont
assez assez sommaires on peut pas on
peut pas se déplacer dans tous les sens
donc ça doit être une organisation quand
même assez assez rigoureuse pour pouvoir
proposer ce type de menu là ça fait
bizarre
c'est
bon vous aussi vous voulez tenter cette
expérience du haut de voltige il reste
encore de rares place pour les prochains
repas dinner in the sky du festival donc
en Chablais
voilà et pour ceux qui ont le vertige
revenons sur terre pour découvrir un
site pour le moins étonnant un nez qu'au
musée de la brasserie témoin d'un
savoir-faire historique le site vosgien
a été retenu par la mission patrimoine
et bénéficiera de financements pour sa
rénovation fermée en 1975 la brasserie
continue de vivre aujourd'hui grâce à
quelques passionnés et amateurs de bière
visite guidé tout en modération de Marie
Daniel rogovitz et de Nicolas bredart
pour vos jeter les vis
elle a été refaite complètement en 1930
et c'est un bel exemple de ce qu'on
appelle l'architecture Art moderne Jean
aimer Morizot ne se lassent pas de faire
visiter l'écomusés de la brasserie de
ville-sur-yon ils sont une quinzaine de
passionnés comme lui à faire vivre les
lieux une souscription publique a été
lancée de quoi lever des fonds
supplémentaires pour des travaux
essentiels d'isolation comme ici dans la
salle des machines nous avons déjà fait
beaucoup de travaux d'entretien mais il
reste encore donc beaucoup de toitures à
rénover sur des parties de la brasserie
quand on aimerait donc intégrer dans le
circuit de visite mais c'est l'histoire
qui a séduit la mission du patrimoine
celle de se bourre aux riches passées où
la fabrication de la bière a débuté au
17e siècle un savoir-faire qui prend une
dimension industrielle grâce à un
entrepreneur alsacien Jacques Lobstein
qui fait bâtir des 1887 la grande
brasserie et malterie Vosges ont
produira à ville-sur-yon des bières
réputé jusqu'en 1975 la salle de
brassage Art Déco et son mobilier
rappelle ses tâches d'or mais à ville
surillon le roi de la bière Gambrinus
est toujours célébré par une joyeuse
équipe de brasseurs bénévoles une
dizaine de brassins ou cuvés sont
réalisés chaque année et samedi dernier
on s'activait autour des cuves
aujourd'hui on est en train de préparer
la première bière de Noël de l'année et
on l'a fait comme elle était faite il y
a 100 ans cette bière là elle était
gardée pour les meilleurs clients de la
brasserie et pour les brasseurs
eux-mêmes donc c'était les étrennes des
brasseurs avoir eu cette année les
faveurs de la mission du patrimoine cela
valait bien une une petite mousse avec
modération
sans modération cette fois-ci la lecture
est une activité essentielle à tous âges
les férus de romans de nouvelle de BD ou
encore de poésie connaissent sûrement la
ville d'Ambierle dans la Loire la balle
la fête du livre c'est un peu toute
l'année jusqu'à 7 librairies étaient
installée dans la commune alors
aujourd'hui elles ne sont plus que trois
avec le développement d'Internet la
passion pour la lecture et certains
métiers du livre n'en restent pas moins
tout à fait intacte comme a pu le
constater Céline arcilia à la
journaliste TL7 la chaîne de la Loire
dans le village d'ambières que l'on
tombe naturellement chez une bouquiniste
en rillettes propose une multitude de
livres d'occasion principalement des
livres de poche ou pour enfants libraire
c'est sa deuxième vie celle qu'elle a
choisie au moment de la retraite par
amour du livre si vous aimez lire vous
ne vous ennuyez jamais
il y a des proverbes comme ça qui
passent sur internet si vous lisez vous
n'êtes jamais seul vous ne serez jamais
seul et et les livres offrent une
multitude de vie les romans les voyages
dans le village vous trouverez trois
libraires et au détour d'une rue vous
pourrez croiser le chemin de Dominique
Le relieure du village toute l'année il
enseigne l'art de la reliure comme en
coudre les pagesjustées la couverture et
enfin la recouvrir pour obtenir un objet
unique
on le nettoie là celui-ci ces livres là
ils ont été fait hier je sais pas
combien elle a peut-être maintenant une
dizaine d'années c'est quand même un
petit peu plus présentable quoi et
depuis quelques années les connaisseurs
j'utilise aussi internet pour chiner on
avait les collectionneurs qui
parcouraient la France les villages du
livre recherche le livre maintenant il
reste chez eux et devant l'ordinateur
ils vont trouver leurs livres donc
toutes les boutiques on vend aussi sur
Internet on a moins de clients dans les
boutiques parce qu'ils peuvent acheter
leur livre ailleurs même sur les marchés
du livre si vous recherchez un livre en
particulier ou si vous aimez juste
découvrir des ouvrages l'idéal est de
venir flâner dans le village d'ambierles
où l'on fait le livre toute l'année
flâner vous y êtes aussi conviés à
partir du 1er décembre prochain à
Montauban la ville accueillera la
cinquième édition francophone du
festival des lanternes un événement haut
en couleur et onirique préparé
actuellement par 80 artisans chinois
comme vous le voyez sur ces images de
nos partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
les décors exigent un travail minutieux
et une organisation au millimètre
l'image et explications dans les
coulisses de la préparation de
l'événement au micro de Clément gassy
nous sommes dans l'atelier de
fabrication qui est exceptionnelle cette
année parce que il est
protégé complètement il n'est pas dans
le parc comme chaque année et nous avons
tous les tous les compartiments de la
fabrication que ce soit la fabrication
des lanternes sur le plan du fer les
ateliers de peinture les ateliers de des
couturières que nous avons ici et nous
avons le stockage bien sûr des pièces
des années passées que l'on va garder et
que l'on va réutiliser on aura par
exemple passage de lotus on va rentrer
dans un tunnel de lotus dans les lotus
ça ne s'est jamais fait et ça reste le
plus grand festival des lanternes
d'Europe
voilà le rendez-vous est donc pris à
partir du 1er décembre à Montauban pour
assister au festival des lanternes
restons dans le sud-ouest de la France
dans cette édition est plus précisément
à Bordeaux où le Musée d'Aquitaine vient
d'inaugurer un parcours dédié aux
personnes en situation de handicap
sensorielle celui-ci permet notamment au
malvoyant de découvrir certaines œuvres
historiques grâce aux toucher concernés
également l'ensemble du public qui peut
profiter d'une nouvelle interactivité
culturelle et précision d'Alixe Fourcade
pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
au Musée d'Aquitaine on peut désormais
toucher le Palais Gallien Florence et
malvoyante et pour elle c'est une
première je suis pas de Bordeaux vous
pouvez pas les Galiens j'en avais
beaucoup entendu parler j'avoue que
j'imaginais pas ça du tout comme ça ce
que je trouve génial aussi c'est cette
démarche finalement d'avoir voulu être
tellement précis dans la représentation
pour qu'au final nous on puisse vraiment
se faire une idée de comment était
l'architecture de ce genre de bâtiment
le Musée d'Aquitaine propose depuis
quelques mois un parcours sensoriel 29
stations jalonnent l'exposition
permanente avec des éléments à toucher
sentir lire en braille et aussi dans les
semaines à venir des vidéos à
disposition sur des tablettes en langage
des signes synonyme d'une nouvelle
indépendance au sein du musée pour les
malentendants c'est vrai que souvent
quand il y a des projections par exemple
dans les musées il y a pas toujours de
sous-titres certaines pièces ont même
été construites par des personnes
handicapées en partenariat avec les
associations armélioration et le Gyps
comme rosace dont Jean-Claude est très
fier
de temps passé sur les 150 000 visiteurs
annuels du musée 2000 sont en situation
de handicap ce nouveau parcours a bien
évidemment été réfléchi pour leur
correspondre mais aussi plus largement
pour séduire tous les publics avec des
propositions plus interactives on est
amené musée à essayer d'innover toujours
et à proposer des choses différentes
quitte à faire des choses différentes il
faut essayer d'englober le maximum de
diversité dedans ce parcours sensoriel
s'étend de la préhistoire jusqu'à
l'époque contemporaine
contemporaine elle les assurément la
piscine de doulien dans la Somme s'offre
une nouvelle jeunesse et se convertit en
écrin artistique elle aussi vouée à la
démolition le site a été investi par une
vingtaine de graffeurs agitation
aquatique laisse place au silence du
street art pour une exposition jusqu'à
la fin de l'année un sujet de Jérémy
Oubron TV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord
regardez
l'ancienne piscine municipale de
Doullens revêt un nouveau visage dans le
bassin jusqu'au vestiaire en passant par
les douches des créatures marines hors
de désormais les murs de ce musée
éphémère un adieu ou en couleur pour un
lieu voué à la destruction
c'était notre piscine c'était c'est un
peu nous qui s'en va avec quoi
actuellement je trouve ça bien ça lui
offre une nouvelle chance
des années qu'elle n'avait plus remis
les pieds ici Jacqueline redécouvre ce
lieu où elle a travaillé 25 ans vous la
reconnaissez votre piscine si je regarde
pas les parce que il y a tellement vécu
des heures ici mais bon on a fait c'est
nous qui avons commencé le premier
Téléthon ici qu'on avait fait le premier
Téléthon de la région avec le projet
transition la piscine le pôle des
cultures urbaines de la Somme a réuni 17
streets artistes venus de toute la
France entre peinture collage et trompe
l'oeil les techniques se sont
entremêlées pour créer une immersion
quasi totale on a deux artistes qui sont
derrière nous qui s'appelle Nikita et
SWEO qui eux sont vraiment spécialisés
dans les anamorphoses au sol donc on a
laissé vraiment carte blanche aux
artistes avec simplement une ligne
directive qui était le milieu le milieu
naturel en fait aquatique ce nouveau
souffle la municipalité il tenait en
avril dernier après 40 années de service
l'espace de désir fermer ses portes
prématurément en cause une avarie
technique les visiteurs ont jusqu'au 30
décembre pour profiter de l'exposition
ensuite la piscine marque Revaux
s'éteindra définitivement pour laisser
la place à une résidence senior
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]